[Applause]
hello
I wanted to let everyone know that I I
live in New York and I flew out this
morning because my story actually needs
to be told in Los Angeles this city
chewed me up and spit me out is there is
there anyone here from New Jersey anyone
so I'm a typical Jersey girl my my goals
in life and my dreams were very
one-dimensional it was to get myself to
New York and have a successful career
and you know I tracked that I was doing
it living this city had a job had an
apartment and it came time to apply for
business schools and it wasn't on my
radar to leave New York I you know that
was the serious city that's the city of
hustle I didn't even think about going
anywhere else despite there's you know
schools all over that are amazing but I
went through a terrible breakup and at
that point I just wanted to get as far
as I could from New York City
the furthest it could take me so I threw
in my application to USC and I wasn't
really concerned about making this
cross-country move I I thought you know
I've watched the hills I get it and I'm
a freakin New Yorker like I'm gonna run
circles around this city it's not gonna
be a problem so there was one problem it
was 2008 it was the belly of the beast
of the recession I worked in private
equity I was getting literally a degree
that was depreciating in value on a
daily basis in the evenings I I could
barely get my car from the Brentwood
Country Market to Whole Foods without a
problem so I was running circles around
no one no one and you know it was a
rough start to what would be a rough
seven years here I had six different
jobs
I went from finance to online dating to
working for a beverage incubator to then
the agency side
and it was it was I always had to have
this kind of side hustle
so my side hustle was working with a lot
of startups and new companies to try to
figure out how they could pitch money
what their marketing strategy was what
their branding strategy was was and
these these jobs this side hustle have
had no money I did a lot of things for
pro bono or for sweat equity so on top
of that I had to have a cash hustle and
my cash hustle was I was a nanny I was a
driver despite my poor driving I was a
bookkeeper and during the holidays I
could even be found on Doheny slinging
Christmas trees at mister green trees so
it was humbling it was clear I was not
lower in Conrad this was not the hills
and I think where it brought me was I
had all these unconventional jobs jobs
that did not require me to be at a desk
from 9:00 to 6:00 and it really forced
me to meet a lot of people and through
those moments I met I just built my
community in Los Angeles and a lot of
the friends here and the people that I
met during this time when far and beyond
the bounds of normal friendship to help
me with my fledgling career one example
would be and two of these women are here
tonight I had I was the marketing
director of a healthy soda flawed flawed
from the beginning and two of my
girlfriend's started a company where
they would come to my beverage events
and they would hair chalk and that was a
way to lure people over to try this
disgusting drink and potentially draw
them in and buy it
I mean who's who has friends like that I
mean that's amazing
so despite you know building this
community and all the support I felt I
really did
my breaking point here and you know my
agency got purchased by a holding
company
I got priced out of my apartment in
Venice and I had no boyfriend so I
thought I'm really lost I'm 33 I don't
know what the next move is clearly I've
made a lot of bad decisions so I'm gonna
do what rational people do and I'm gonna
make an appointment with a psychic who
you know my mom friends in the Palisades
recommended her and they swear that
their life turned out the way this woman
said it would so I make an appointment
and you know she was very professional
she asked all of the information you
know in advance
she had charts and all these things and
the first order of business for me was
what the am I supposed to be doing
with my life nothing is working nothing
is working out for me what am I meant to
be doing is something's not working and
she was quiet and she said your career
house is empty I said oh really because
I work like a dog since I was 14 so tell
me how my career house is empty and she
said it just means that you know this
life is not about success or working or
your career it's about relationships
that's lovely I've spent a lot of time
and money to the tone of six figures on
this career and on this dream so how is
it all gonna work out and she said
you're gonna meet a man and he's going
to be successful and you're gonna help
him be successful so I thought about it
I was like okay so I have some
opportunities rolling in I need to make
a decision about where I'm gonna go and
what I'm gonna do next and she said well
whatever you do it needs to be like you
know take it easy it doesn't need to be
as ambitious as you've been and you know
I can help you make that next move when
these offers come in you call me and we
will make that decision
so I'm driving home I'm digesting all of
this and I'm thinking well I'm not gonna
die alone and broke there's that but I
mean is this really what my path is is
this really wondering how I'm gonna be
happy and in that moment I had some
clarity and I was like I have
lost my mind if I think that a psychic
in the valley is gonna make my next
career choice I need to leave here so
the next week when the offers came in I
took the most ambitious and aggressive
one I could take and I moved to New York
I had an offer
working for Gary Vaynerchuk and his
agency which is not not an easy task and
it was the best decision I ever made
and my whole LA experience really didn't
make any sense to me until I started
working it we work and it's not for the
obvious reasons it's not because I
embrace startups and really worked in
that community here but it's because I
understand the importance of people
feeling supported and for people showing
up for other people because of what the
LA community did for me so to work for a
company that our mission is to create
spaces where people can have those human
connections and where companies of all
sizes and individuals can feel supported
and where they can thrive is is amazing
and awesome so I'm sure you're wondering
about my future husband and if he's he's
found me yet he has not but hasn't
happened I didn't listen to her but my
shirt says boss and that's really all I
ever wanted so thank you
you
[Music]